[Applause]
[Music]
there's no one even following us don't
look back look up
uh I think we're about to have some
company
start the car what what
else
Laura this is
me
parallel contact me well you know you've
always said that you've wished you'd met
me earlier
here I am
[Music]
do you remember this I mean this is
happening to me it already happened to
you right
unless it works more like a Multiverse
where each room will create an office
my God we watched too many movies
[Music]
so bunny 50 is it really bad
it's not great find him
get ready to run
foreign
stop time travel matter being invented
boom
what's your plan well I'm not gonna
explain my plan to a 12 year old nerd
with him
but I know somebody who does Dad
I'm the Godfather of time travel the
atom project
hey kids
oh yeah
[Music]
30 years trying to get away from the me
that was you
I'll tell you what
what
you were the best part all along
it's good to be so smart
but you get to be so dumb
let's try
[Music]